okay one second we'll come to that in a
minute I want to give this lovely person
a chance for more suitcases great
suitcases
you said Canadian tuxedos I like it
feels slightly pointed doesn't it
Canadian tuxedos suitcases tranch
here what you guys gonna suggest
dodgeball one second this guy got in
first with dodgeball what did you say
merry-go-round and desalinization yeah
did you add the extra syllable do you
say desalination yeah I think he ballsed
up on it I think that's okay that's okay
maybe you didn't roll by the tape
suitcase Canadian tuxedo dodgeball
merry-go-round salinization will do
something with it this segment here what
you guys gonna come up with wow there
were two what was that
okay foreskin and the big bend which is
ironically what I call mine because I've
suggested foreskin that feels like I've
kind of implanted that in you which
again not literally
I like that you said Big Ben you called
it the Big Ben which is is wonderful the
Big Ben merry-go-round dodgeball
salinization Canadian tuxedo and
suitcase and this is the final
suggestion guys and already this is ritu
more than we used to 1 1 second this
this loud people up here a safety
keeping spend ow
oh that van Gogh right as in the Dutch
painter van Gogh yeah okay cool you
pronounced in fact go over there okay
that's fine what are you guys thinking
yeah van go [ __ ] yourself Chris but I
also heard corporate espionage so I'm
going to combine that will have Van Gogh
or Van Gogh but the van geo gh is
corporate espionage merry-go-round
dodgeball salinization Canadian tuxedo
and suitcase and the Big Ben lovely
there there's some good suggestions you
might need to remember them for me now
this this is for a reason I'm just gonna
get them a walk off this is for a little
thing a little treat I guess called a
freestyle rap and that is a rap made up
on the spot based entirely on those of
judges he's not prepared is not
rehearsed you'll never be seen again and
do not worry it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously embarassingly
toe-curling Lee bad as you are expecting
a 29 year old privately educated middle
class white British boy to be you seem
unconvinced but don't worry do you want
to roll that tape
I'm excited for these a table of 10
people are as well and they pump a
little bit the word on the street big
and large he's working in his painting
and corporate espionage coming over here
undercover and making clear others band
goes by when he's only wanna hear no
death perception if he had one Arvid but
as long as you're on his right side
he can heal you and spy want you to
employ banjo he'll take care of you
he'll just tap in the bushes for several
hours occupy himself by painting
sunflowers and when someone comes past
that you need to steal the dates are
from two sub speed you'll get it yeah
and then he will take it to you and say
boss this is the paintin and you'll say
well done you're the boss van Gogh and
he'll say is pronounced van Gogh that no
one even minds when he's on the case
keep the straw cap in the little
briefcase when these wires transatlantic
Lee obviously something he never lived
to see because he killed himself very
sadly stateside I like to get a nice
briefcase Samsonite every
protected the brand I selected the best
come on everybody yes I elected get a
better place than the home breath go get
one from Target hurts your hand you'll
get a little blister yeah you'll feel it
pushing on the biological choice battles
gonna push it but my solution sorry
wouldn't fit in sex or the word that you
said which was knitting but we will move
on ever so slow and talk about double
denim Canadian tuxedo it is he a guy
with jeans and then up top also made
from dreams you might stand there
respect as a tension and say never see
the guy in low slow flight intended I
wasn't aware it felt like a heckle could
maybe in some speedo yeah Tesla met oppa
that's okay the words in my mind spin
like a merry-go-round in this salty like
say line they come to me I never read
before I move the text terrorists we
might play in dodgeball and let us talk
about this weird situation
dodgeball merry-go-round salad 9 station
or salad nation
like JD Salinger and spin it around like
them to mr. ballet detail I'm throwing
balls like the Ben Stiller movie the
horse goes up and down yes so rudely
it's like Mary Poppins on the circular
ride having lots of fun and then they it
when she's outside the last thing that
we need to do a slightly [ __ ] right
remind me what it was going to do we
combined it what was it
[Music]
Jenna what is the one do we do your ones
already how we did oh that's one game
for a break I got it Turner
yeah apologies the pause and the stuff
let me set this straight Big Ben is the
belle mother clock the Box hours Paul
the Queen Elizabeth this is a fact you
can look it up online after you've left
but Big Ben oh holy hell I love the
resounding plan when you slam that Bell
the rapper in the middle no apology I
studied the Big Bend because I love
Cap'n ology which is the science of bell
ringing you're welcome